- [Instructor] In a previous
video, we asked ourselves
a very important question.
As the moon has its 28-day
cycle around the Earth,
we talked about how a
new moon is when the moon
is between the earth and the
sun, and so from the Earth's
point of view, or from the
point of view of someone
standing on Earth, you're
seeing the side of the moon
that is not lit up.
But an obvious question is
why doesn't that block out
the sun every time we are
in a new moon position?
After all, the sun would be out
here, 93 million miles away,
and so wouldn't the moon block
out the sun in that scenario?
And we also talked about
when the moon is on the other
side of the Earth, when we
would typically see a full moon,
the Earth is between the moon and the sun.
Why doesn't the Earth block
the light from the sun
that's being reflected on the moon?
So the big question is, why
don't we see a solar eclipse
every new moon and why
don't we see a lunar eclipse
every full moon?
If we wanna ask the same
question, looking at the scale
of the Earth and the moon,
we can see it right over here
and so this would be the new moon position
where the moon is between
the Earth and the sun.
The key explanation for why
we do not have a solar eclipse
every time we are in the new moon position
is that the rotation of
the moon around the Earth
is not in the exact same
plane as the rotation
of the Earth around the sun.
It actually turns out that the
plane of the moon's rotation
is at a five-degree angle with the plane
of the Earth and the sun.
If this is the sun here, and
this is not drawn to scale
by any means, this is the
Earth, and so the Earth
is in its orbit, something like that,
the moon's orbit does not
sit exactly in this plane,
it does not sit exactly in this plane,
the moon's orbit is at
a five-degree angle,
is at a five-degree angle to this plane,
so depending what time of year you are at
and where the moon is in its cycle,
the moon will often sit
above or below the plane
of the Earth's orbit, so for
example, from the vantage point
of the Earth, the moon will
vary up to five degrees
above the plane of Earth's
rotation around the sun,
often known as the ecliptic,
and five degrees below that.
And so you can see here,
the shadow of the moon
will only fall on the Earth
when the moon is crossing
through the plane of the
rotation of Earth around the sun.
Many times, the moon might
be here or here or here
and in those times, the
shadow will not hit the Earth.
Now what you do see here,
depicted in this picture,
would be a solar eclipse.
Now there's two things
that I've drawn here
and this is important for
understanding a solar eclipse,
what you see in those yellow lines,
that's the umbra of the
moon, so if you are in,
if you're at that point right
over here in this picture,
then the moon will
completely block out the sun
and it turns out depending
on the solar eclipse,
where that umbra is hitting the Earth,
it might only be a few
hundred miles where the moon
completely blocks out the sun.
What you see in this dark blue
color, that is the penumbra,
that is the outer shadow and
if you're in one of those
areas, you will see the moon
partially block out the sun.
Now this is the exact same reason,
the fact that the plane of its
rotation is at a five-degree
angle with the plane of
rotation of the Earth
around the sun, that's also
the reason why we don't see
a lunar eclipse every 28 days.
Here we see different
scenarios where the moon
is on the other side
of Earth from the sun,
when the moon is what we would
call a full moon position,
and as we can see, it can
vary five degrees above
the plane of the Earth and
the sun or five degrees
below that and you're only
going to get a scenario
of a lunar eclipse when
the moon happens to fall
in the shadow of the
Earth and here once again,
between the yellow
lines, you see the umbra,
and between the blue lines,
you see the penumbra,
which would be kind of a partial shadow.
So next time you look up at the moon,
hopefully you are armed
with a lot more information
to think about how it's oriented
with respect to the Earth.
In fact, now when you
look at the moon at night,
you can usually look at the
moon and tell which direction
the sun is in and based on
that, you can even think about
what time of day it is
and you could figure out
east, west, north, and south.
And we've talked a lot
about the sun, in fact,
this entire video and the one before it
is all about light from the sun.
And just to finish off
with a little bit of awe,
let's just appreciate how
large and how far the sun is.
As we mentioned before, this
is a scaled representation
of the Earth and the moon,
the moon being roughly
240,000 miles away from Earth.
If we were to try to model the sun here,
it is 400 times as far,
depending on your screen size,
it would be a football field to the right
of your screen and you
would have something
roughly the size of a beach
ball to represent the sun.
If you wanted to just
compare the sizes of the sun
to the Earth and the moon, here you go.
The sun is huge.